thank God it's amazing it's crazy
VidCon 2016 took over the Anaheim
Convention Center in California for the
seventh year et was there to chat with
YouTube's most famous faces welcome it
to camp Ichi this year saw about 30,000
attendees but there was a cloud over the
convention the recent death of christina
grimmie a singer who had made her name
on youtube she was shot and killed while
signing autographs for fans it felt like
it could have been me I've been in that
situation like reaching out to my fan
for a hug and I was on my book tour so I
was in the middle of doing these I had
one of the thing night it happened it's
just heartbreaking a big part of VidCon
is meet and greets with fans fans who
feel like they know these YouTube
creators when you watch someone a lot
online for example you feel like you're
really close friends with them but to us
you know we don't necessarily know the
person as well so organizers responded
directly to Christina's death and up
security I think they even doubled the
number of security guards that are here
how did you react when you heard that
that was happening well first of all I
feel happy because I felt safe you know
that was of course a worry
it's weird though because you know with
feeling more safe and feeling better
about it there's also that thing that
kind of bums me out which is why we
can't have get as close and personal
with our audience and viewers singer
Marilyn Bailey new Christina and told us
she has dealt with stalkers so Madeline
has to take precautions when it becomes
a significant age difference or somebody
who I can tell is getting very very
attached to me I try to find a way to
either say hey look I love you I love
the attention and yet I have tons of
people I had to talk to you so I can't
like dedicate a lot of time to one
person still positivity prevails
it's important for people to be safe but
also experience it in a way that is
special and I think that's happening I'm
also really proud of all these
my parents for not letting our us as a
country live in fear because that's not
what what life is about we should all
come out and have a good time